[Music]
good morning good afternoon good evening
my name is jessica chung i'm an
admissions officer
at the stanford graduate school of
business mba admissions office
i'm joined by a panel of my amazing
colleagues to talk about letters of
reference today
so i want to start by going over what to
expect in
our time during our time together first
i'll have our panelists introduce
themselves um and then we'll start with
a few
prepared questions um just to give
everybody the same base understanding of
the letter of reference what is the
letter of reference what are its
what are its purposes what does a strong
letter of reference look like
and then we want to turn it over to your
questions so that q
a box where you've been saying hello to
us keep using that to
enter your questions for us you can also
upvote other attendees questions
if you see a question that reflects
something that you're curious about as
well
and overall we're going to spend about
50 minutes together
and over the course of those 50 minutes
our goals are to help you
better understand how we use letters of
reference
and to provide recommenders so people
who are writing those letters for you
with tips and best practices on how to
write a supportive letter
and this video will be shared on youtube
so it can
continue to be a resource that you share
with people
who are supporting you in the
application process
so with that i will turn it over to our
panelists
to introduce themselves um will why
don't you get us started
hi everyone i'm will one of the
admission officers
here and one of the qualities that i
value is empathy as well
i love that yes i'm going to ask the
rest of our panelists to
also complete the sentence that we've
had our attendees completing about
equality that you value
uh alison why don't you go next hi
everybody i'm allison
with the mba admissions office i would
say especially in the context of letters
of reference i would say i
value transparency helps me get to know
you
awesome thank you anna-lysa hi everyone
my name is elisa
i'm also a member of the nba admissions
team here excited to join you guys today
um not necessarily related to letters of
reference but i really value
humor and approaching things um with
with kind of a positivity and and
ability to laugh
awesome thank you all um so let's first
get started with some
baseline questions to get all of us on
the same page
what is the letter of reference and what
is its purpose in the
application process
i'm going to throw it over to allison
okay
um uh the letter of reference uh
helps us to see you through someone
else's eyes
so as you know there's different parts
of the application
and so the essays uh let us
see how you see yourself and the letters
of reference
uh let us see how others see you
yeah absolutely i think that's a great a
great short and pivoy way to explain
what the letter references references
as you all are attendees are asking
people and advocates in your life to
write your letters of recommendation
um will alisa do you have anything that
you would add to that
um i think i might add also you know for
those of you who may have joined us for
other events
um you're probably aware of the criteria
we use when we're looking
at an application and um whether it's
intellectual vitality or demonstrated
leadership or even just getting to know
you
the personal qualities and contributions
we see a lot of examples of that in the
letters of reference so
um when you think you know what is a
letter of reference what
uh makes a strong letter of reference
you know uh
like allison said we learn a lot about
you
hearing from other people and obviously
the letter of reference um both of them
that you would submit play a pivotal
role in that and they give
us some really tangible examples of
things that we're looking for
especially a lot of times demonstrated
leadership um comes out you know we're
asking
the people who write your letter of
reference to tell us what have you done
and how have you done it and that really
helps us understand you as a person and
how you approach
problem solving and how you get things
done
yeah i really appreciate at least how
you mentioned evidence and examples i
think
applying to business school in
particular
letters of reference take on a slightly
different
um spirit maybe than if you were
applying to
for those of you who may remember
applying to college
those tended to be very general if
you're applying to maybe an academic or
phd based
graduate program it's going to be much
more focused on like how does this
person kind of consume
and kind of produce knowledge how do
they absorb and share right
for the business school context that is
one element
that might be shared in there but it's
not evidence how have you performed
how have you um what kind of presence
have you had in
especially organizational settings that
word
impact will come up a lot like what's
the impact you've had
what kind of footprints have you left
behind so i think
over the course of today like i like
unpacking that will be helpful because
there is a slight different
nuance to letters of rack for business
school than i've seen
um even having worked in other
admissions offices before
yeah absolutely and i think um your
answers
also give us insight into what makes a
strong letter recommendation and i think
there should be like a
underlying double underline highlight
bolded around
evidence i think throughout the
application process
we're not just looking for what you've
accomplished but we're interested in how
you have
accomplished that and as alison said
hearing other voices in your application
speak to
not just what you've accomplished but
how can be really really helpful
how have you demonstrated leadership are
you able to
creatively problem-solve do you take
what's given to you and see beyond
what's given to you do you work beyond
the expectations that are given to you
do you make your workplaces more
inclusive
are you able to mobilize and influence
other people to get on board with your
ideas like those are all things that
are really really helpful for us when we
think about your leadership potential
when we think about some of your
personal qualities and contributions to
the
organizations that you've been a part of
so thank you all for that introduction
to letters of recommendation
um i'm going to ask a couple more of our
prepared questions and then turn it over
to the q a box so for our attendees
please continue submitting
your amazing and thoughtful questions
and please continue uploading questions
that
you're curious to learn more about um
i'm also wondering if you all or
panelists have any
tips for helping set your recommenders
up for success
um i think uh
obviously writing a letter of reference
for someone is it takes time it takes
energy
how do how do applicants make sure that
their
letter writers are set up for success
and to be the best advocates possible i
can
start us off i think the most important
thing is give them plenty of warning
plenty of time you know probably how
busy your recommender is
and i would say take them out to coffee
or tea or virtual coffee or tea
and help them understand what the
timeline is
and what the questions are
you can also remind them of maybe some
specific examples that they that they
might want to include
as we said earlier evidence is so
important so it's those
specifics anecdotes details examples so
you want to
be sure to remind them to support
whatever their assertions are
with examples you would be surprised
that we don't often get
like really you know negative
recommendations where somebody's being
completely
trashed you know that doesn't happen
very often but more often than we would
like
we get recommendations where they might
say jessica
is the best person we hired in the last
five years
you know period end of sentence end of
answer
you know no examples of what made
jessica
such an amazing hire so um you want to
make sure that they
include examples and that was a great
example
[Laughter]
yeah i would also say that for many like
we just talked about like how the
business school
letter of wreck is a little bit
different so we're going to be asking
all of our recommenders the same two
questions they're along the lines of
like
how has this person performed um
relative to qualified peers the other is
like tell us about a time where there
was feedback
so even sharing those questions and
talking through and understanding like
okay here's a great structure and
they're actually asking
for what they're um looking for and then
the other thing you can share with them
is uh the evaluation criteria
website we just talked a lot about
intellectual vitality
demonstrated leadership potential but
those are kind of squishy words
um and they sound very high level but
on that website it actually brings it
down to tangible bite-sized things
that as they're thinking about hey here
are the things jessica has done she's
great
oh i didn't realize that falls under
this bucket
of what they're looking for and so that
could also help cue them into the types
of examples
that they could use to um support their
assertions
absolutely and that's actually um
a great segue to one of the questions in
the q a box and alisa
if you have more to add i definitely
want to make space for that but
juanita in the q a box asked if there is
a package we can share with references
to give them a sense of what stanford is
looking for
i'm going to drop a link in the chat to
more information on letters of reference
and if you scroll towards the bottom
you can see some of the questions the
the questions that we ask and more
information for recommenders so i will
drop in in the chat
uh elisa do you have any other tips for
setting up
recommendation writers for success um no
i mean i think will and allison touched
on
the key things and i would just echo
especially what allison said at the
beginning
to give them time one is just a sign of
respect
that you're giving them the time you're
asking for them to
to take that time to be thoughtful and
provide specifics that will help you um
in your application but also um as many
of you may know about
any application process to business loan
but especially the stanford application
it's an introspective process we ask
lots of questions not only to you but to
you know the recommenders also
and um again just the more time someone
can spend on that
uh to provide those specific concrete
examples that really
help us understand who you are um is
is a great thing so so that was already
said and i just echo that
jessica if i just could add one more
thing when you're
um asking them to be a recommender and
again having these are probably people
you have mentoring relationships
anyway with so you know presumably you
can have an honest conversation
if you detect any reluctance
let them off the hook you know um i
think
what the the reason we sometimes
get those one sentence answers is
somebody
didn't want to turn down the request but
they honestly really don't have time
and they feel rushed and so you want to
make sure that not only
they know you well but they're in a
position to have the time to write a
thoughtful letter
and um and are and are excited to to to
be your advocate
um i would also add especially if there
are folks who might be
writing recommendations watching right
now um
the way we look at the recommendation
it's for those evidence pieces
in context so it doesn't necessarily
mean you have to be versed in
um quote-unquote business language it
also doesn't have to be the most
beautiful like it doesn't have to be
like artistic
writing at all even if sometimes factual
straight to the point here is the impact
this person made
here's the scope of it here's the scale
of it here's what it looks like is this
normal for something at this
individual's level
it have they gone above and beyond and
here are the reasons why
and now here are the ripple effects of
it sometimes getting straight to that
point
is where we find value and hopefully it
helps you save a little bit of time as
well
um i know this can also be a concern
for folks whose like uh
language of writing proficiency is not
english and so again
it's not about kind of how it's written
but what's
written in there in the content um so
know that we are trained and we work
really hard to make sure we're trying to
um suss that stuff out and let the let
the evidence
shine so just wanted to also put that
out there i know there's some folks who
can be
a little hesitant because they're not
sure what a business school
recommendation looks like or or how we
use it and these letters
are not long um correct me if i'm wrong
but typically
the letters are two to four pages would
you say at least unwell
they're not long long letters um uh and
maybe we should
address if your recommender is not
um able to write in english what what
you should do
sure i mean that's a good
achieve i mean i think we're we're
jumping right into some granular things
so we
we can definitely talk about that if
you're um if the primary language of
whoever might be writing your letter of
reference is not english
um they could write in in the language
they're most comfortable in but then we
do ask that it be translated
um into english upon submitting the
letter of reference and again like what
will said
uh perfect grammar syntax
and layout is not what we're looking for
we're looking for
um what they're going to share about you
as a as a
person as someone who worked in their
organization as someone who
had impact you know what did you do how
did you do it
um what was the ripple effect like will
said of what you've done
and that can come through in a
translation again even if the grammar
is not perfect so for those who are
thinking about asking someone whose
primary language is not english please
don't worry about how the translation
might
come across to us that's not where it
doesn't need to be perfect
uh grammar for us to be able like will
said to
see those examples and to understand the
context of the impact that you've made
um so that is something we do ask for
and i think this is leading us into
you know just we've talked about like
allison had great advice if you say
to someone hey you know i'm applying to
business school can you write me a
letter of reference and you sense
hesitation
that's a good good like first hint to
maybe ask someone else but
i think we should step back and talk
about like who
do we want these letters of reference to
be from and why
so um i think that many of you
uh probably know if you've started an
application or looked on our web pages
but
we do ask for two letters of reference
um and we ask that they be from people
who have supervised your work and we
specifically ask that the first one be
from
someone currently supervising your work
and i do see a lot of questions out
there around
um i i maybe had worked for someone for
four years and i just switched jobs and
i'm with someone for only
six weeks now and things like that so so
we can talk about exceptions to this but
in general we ask that
from for the first one to be from
someone currently supervising you again
back to the criteria that we're looking
for um someone who's currently
supervising you is going to be able to
tell us
what have you done and how have you done
it um you know what is the impact that
you're making
in your current role in your current job
in your current organization
um are you taking advantage of
opportunities presented to you are you
going above and beyond all of those
things and you know
we'll get a great sense of that from
someone who currently supervises
um your work there's a lot of times i
mean we
generally give advice around the
questions what do i
do i just started working with someone
they don't know me that well
use your best judgment kind of like what
allison was hinting at if someone's
hesitant when you ask them
to be your your recommender same thing
here
in the sense that um you want to make
sure
that when you really think about what is
this person going to be able to say and
do they know me well enough
that you're asking the right person
right and so you can use your best
judgment if you
have been working for someone for a
short time period or perhaps you're
working for your mom or dad it's a
family business or
perhaps you're a founder of a company
yourself and so there isn't someone that
uh supervises you in a traditional way
then use your best judgment who's going
to be able to provide those concrete
examples
um it could be a member of your board it
could be someone else that you work with
it could be the person you previously
worked for since you're only working for
someone for a few weeks
so again think about what we're looking
for
ultimately this has to sit really well
inside of you the you know
um we always say the best time to apply
is when you feel like your application's
at its best
and we would hate for you to submit your
application and then wish you had asked
someone else or
had a different letter of reference so
again just use your best judgment in
terms of who you ask but
there are a lot of reasons why we ask
for one to be from your current
supervisor and i'm going to pause a
little because i'm talking a lot so
i don't know if will or allison have
anything else to add
yeah i think alisa you're right a lot of
the questions that are coming up in the
q
a box are about how to choose your
recommender and i appreciate that you
went over
what exactly do we ask for so two
letters of reference one from a
current direct supervisor or next best
alternative
because we appreciate that there are as
lisa said many situations in which
you're not able to ask your current
direct supervisor for a letter of
reference
and then another from somebody else who
has supervised your work in some
capacity
um but in addition to that
um do you all have any advice for how to
choose a recommender
um and there are several questions on
this topic i think one that
has sort of risen to the top in the q a
boxes from conica
who i think this is coming from
recognizing that our process is holistic
that the letters of recommendation
are one of many pieces of your
application so konica asks do you prefer
do you prefer a um that similar
characteristics about a candidate
um are highlighted through both
recommendations or are you looking for
different characteristics
highlighted from each recommender
so i think again kind of asking the
question like how do you choose your
recommenders and like
beyond evidence how do you decide
how do you think about what story the
recommendations should tell
and how should it contribute to the
overall story of your
application yeah first of all we have no
preference
and it's really up to you how you
present yourself
um you know the questions to the
recommenders are on our website so you
can see them
and i would say be asking yourself who
can best answer these questions
and if you're lucky enough to have
multiple people maybe there's two that
have
uh you know more robust examples or more
examples that you know they can include
in the letter
and as far as um uh you know current
versus previous jobs
i think that's um really how you want to
present your story i mean if you want to
show
perhaps growth over time um in terms of
your own development maybe you want to
get a previous recommend a previous
supervisor and then a current supervisor
if you want to really dig deep into
current impact and accomplishments maybe
you want two people
from your current company and you know
we've certainly seen
excellent uh excellent recommendations
from
both scenarios and i'm sure they're you
know there are other ways to think about
it but it's it's really up to you
how you want to you know present your
your narrative
yeah i would even make it
easier than that sometimes trying to
over strategize
might have you trying to find different
people to fit this perfect
image of who you want to present
yourself as um
when one way i think about it as well is
sometimes the people who are providing
those perspectives
as alison and elisa were talking about
they're your champions already these are
the folks who might be your mentors
advocates and sponsors in different
facets of your life
and you'd be surprised at how many
people even within the same organization
maybe because they're on different teams
or at their different levels or if they
work with you on different projects
even in those instances they might have
different
understandings of how you've operated
and have had
different experiences with you um and so
it really does come back to what allison
was saying
at the beginning it's how have other
people
like how have other people been impacted
by and what was their experience with
that
how can they communicate that to us and
everybody will do that a little bit
differently
and and we definitely trust you to
figure out who is going to do that best
for you
you may want to strategize if that
becomes overwhelming because i know
sometimes it can be
this is gonna sound weird because it's
like the one like trust the unit like
trust your instincts trust your gut if
something says
i think this is someone who can you know
really advocate for me and it feels
like a good choice go with that one
regardless of their relationship to your
other
um writer
absolutely elisa anything you would want
to add here
i think i think we'll cover that really
well i don't have anything to add
specifically to that awesome um
looking in the q a box again
um and there are a couple
questions about timing as well so
on the letters of reference page on our
website we
suggest asking somebody who has worked
with you within the last three years
and there are a couple questions about
timing whether it's okay to ask somebody
from a previous role um even going
beyond three years ago say five years
ago do you all have any advice on
sort of figuring out the the timing
of your relationship with your letters
of recommenders
any advice there um
i think it was mentioned earlier you
know kind of what you've done
in the past is a really good predictor
of what you might
how you might approach problems or lead
in the future
um and so when we ask that one of the
letters of reference be from someone
who has worked with you in the past
three years um
you know that's because we're we're
looking for current
uh or more recent examples of what have
you done
and and how have you done it what has
your impact been
that said earlier i also said use your
best judgment
so you know if there is if
for instance if you're going to maybe
choose someone who
um is from four years ago or like i said
you're choosing someone who's not your
direct supervisor for one of those
reasons we cited you do have the chance
to explain to us
why um and that would provide
context for us if you don't but you know
there's
definitely a reason why we asked that it
be within the last three years um
again looking for that more recent
examples of what you've done
um and we're looking for it specifically
in the job you've most recently been in
um but again you have to use your best
judgment about who
you're asking um i saw
a question to you around um you know for
instance maybe you have been at a
company for a really long time so you're
going to choose
two people from the same company and
that's absolutely fine
so someone's asking that you know if
those are the two people who can really
provide
the best um examples again of what
you've done
and um know you the best out of everyone
you might be thinking
about asking for a letter of reference
um then again
if that feels right to you um that's
absolutely fine
but like we said you could also choose
your second one to be
from someone else who has supervised you
in some way it could be somewhere else
you used to work
it could be um that someone has
supervised you
in an activity outside of work in some
way
um so again this is really about you
thinking
through um you know all the people
you're thinking about asking
and and who might be able to provide
those examples in the best light for you
those of you who are in client services
business um
businesses client might be really good
choice so
doesn't have to be a current supervisor
yeah i'll add one wrinkle to this for
folks who might be reapplying
um you might have asked recommenders
before you might be asking the same
recommenders again
again trust your instincts we have no
preference if you choose the same people
you choose different people because
maybe the relationships in your life
have changed
if you are asking the same people um
i definitely recommend you ask them to
write the letter again from fresh eyes
even though it might be the exact same
questions their relationship the things
they have seen you done since you last
applied might have additional
information
or ways that they now understand your
impact on in your organization or
whatever setting you were in um so i
think that's one thing
i would definitely recommend at least in
terms of
time recency just have them come with
fresh eyes
um which would you know that's what
we're doing we're trying to look at who
you are in the here and now
that's great advice thanks um
we also have a question about deferred
admission
um would you all be able to speak to
sort of the differences between
academic letters of recommendation
professional letters of recommendation
and any
any tips or differences that you would
want attendees to keep in mind
as they sort of navigate their choices
between the two
um for deferred admits um
so specifically people who might be
currently a full-time student
who are thinking about applying to the
gsb um
we evaluate you know each application
with the same criteria
that i mentioned at the beginning so so
demonstrated leadership potential
intellectual vitality personal qualities
and contributions so
um we suggest that you select
recommenders then who
in some way have supervised you knowing
that you don't have years of work
experience like someone who has already
graduated from undergrad and worked for
a few years
but perhaps someone has supervised your
extracurricular activities or perhaps
you've had a part-time internship or
even a part-time job
summer internship a job through your
years of at college
there's lots of things that you have
probably been involved in
as a full-time student that demonstrate
leadership where you've been able to
have an impact and so
again um in those roles has there been
someone supervising you
in some capacity um that might be a good
person to think about asking for your
letter of reference this could be
an academic letter of reference then in
that sense perhaps you've been doing
research
um for a professor and they know you
very well and they're able to speak to
the impact that you've had and what
you've done
um in in working with them so that's
perfectly acceptable too but also we
encourage you just to think about
the extracurricular activities you may
have been involved in
internships part-time work all of those
are good places
to start thinking about asking someone
for a letter of reference
i would also tie this back to will's
reminder from the beginning about
business school recommendations being a
little bit different
so if you do ask a professor or an
academic to write a recommendation
you want to make sure they understand
they're not writing a recommendation for
a phd program
this is a a management program where we
are looking for
evidence of leadership potential
um so again um often
from professors we will get a letter
that says
you know elisa sat in the third row in
the class
she got a b plus a midterm here's the
syllabus
um and that's not really helpful to us
in terms of
assessing your leadership potential but
if
they're talking about impact you've had
perhaps as a ta or in the lab
or knowledge that you created that
really pushed
you know boundaries that's the kind of
uh of thing that that can be helpful to
us
nice job with that b plus elisa i heard
that class is really hard
awesome thank you all um
let me see there is another great
question
in here um what advice can i give my
recommenders to best
boost my chances of being accepted or
to best support them in
writing a letter of reference so we we
talked about setting up recommenders for
success but are there tips that
um applicants can give to their
recommenders if their recommenders are
feeling uncertain
or are not super confident about what
should go in that letter what what can
they say
uh maybe three things so one definitely
share this video with them hopefully
they'll be able to pull out some content
that will help them understand and
figure out where some additional
resources are
provide them with the website uh the
evaluation criteria to help them
understand the things that we're looking
for
and then my third thing would be if they
have questions
have them contact us directly sometimes
things might get lost
in that game of telephone where they're
asking you and then you're asking us
if they're able to ask us we're able to
make that connection directly and if
there's any clarification that needs to
happen
um there's not going to be that extra
time lag in between
and hopefully that's one less thing you
have to do in that realm of upward
management
which again is going to be a natural
part of this but yeah definitely
if they have questions have them reach
out to us and we can we can help out
awesome allison elisa anything you'd add
tips for recommenders
those are great tips i don't feel like i
would add anything to tips
but in general you know we want them to
be authentic
and true to themselves so um this
question is kind of stemming from a
place of like what
do you think we want to hear and
hopefully we've been able to convey
to you today like that that we're
looking for uh tangible examples of your
impact and specifics like allison said
you know
hearing that um will is the best person
i've worked with in five years
is um is great that's a really positive
statement but it
isn't uh specific in terms of reasons
why
perhaps um and in terms of
kind of evidence of impact and things
like that so
again encourage them to be as specific
as possible
but more so just encourage them to
answer the questions
you know honestly we talked about things
that we value at the beginning you know
it would be transparent
um you know there isn't anything there
isn't a format or a statement or
something that we're
looking for we're looking for those
examples and we're really hoping to try
to understand
who you are as a person um
throughout your application and there's
lots of different areas of the
application where we find that and
letters of reference are definitely one
of those
areas i would just add too that i think
sometimes
applicants and maybe recommenders worry
about
gee i better not say that i ever that
the candidate
ever struggled with anything or ever you
know
grew in their job it's like you know we
don't expect you to
you know spring from the womb you know
perfectly formed in this
you know uh uh you know superlative uh
uh performer um so so uh
it can actually make a recommendation
more credible
if um if they're honest about you know
maybe there were areas where you
struggled
uh in your job or things you know i mean
we all have development areas so
um you know how you um how you um
dealt with um constructive criticism and
and
things that that you may have grown
grown from
yeah i think at the heart of it it's
what stood out
to them about kind of their interactions
with you
and that is a very open-ended statement
because that's going to be different for
everyone
and yes we talk a lot about intellectual
vitality demonstrated leadership
potential
um but we are also not looking for any
particular balance within there
and so as you're talking to the folks
that you might be
asking or they're asking what are what
are some things to think about
like just let them know that we don't
have a preference for that bounce
focus on the things that were meaningful
to them that stood out to them and they
feel like
should be called out in support of you
knowing that everybody's letters are
going to have a different balance of
different things
no two people are gonna be called the
best people that they work with for the
exact same reasons
or if they are maybe they've done it for
you know there's different ways that
they've been able to achieve that so
again let the recommenders speak from
their perspective
kind of in their words about the things
that stood out about you because that's
going to be different for
all of you yeah absolutely and
to um to allison's point one of the
questions that we ask letters of right
or that we ask in the letters of
reference
is describe the most important piece of
constructive feedback you have given the
applicant
please detail the circumstances and the
applicant's response
as you can tell from this panel like all
of us
admissions officers we're human they're
humans reading your
letters we have our own flaws and
vulnerabilities too
and so we know what it's like to make
mistakes and to grow and to get feedback
so we don't expect anybody to be perfect
in this process
and one of the things we are interested
in is how do you grow
what do you do when you're given
constructive feedback so we're not
expecting perfection in these letters
we're expecting to learn more about you
and
your how you contribute to the
communities and organizations you're a
part of
how you grow those are the things that
we're interested in learning about
in these letters um and as you look
through some of the
other materials about the letters of
recommendation like you'll see
exactly what questions we ask so that's
something you can do to prepare and
that's another way that you can prepare
your
the writers of your letters of
recommendation
i wanted to do maybe a lightning round
of what we call tactical practical
questions
um and so these might be a little more
fast paced but i see that there are a
lot of questions about
word limits and some of the more
tactical and practical aspects of
writing letters of recommendation so i
wanted to do a little lightning round of
that if that's cool with our
panelists okay um this is not something
i seeded beforehand so i just wanted to
check
so katrina has asked a question that has
been upvoted
um could i ask whether the word limit
for
letters of recommendation is a hard
limit i understand that the limit is
usually up to
500 words but i've heard past applicants
saying that the letter of wreck is more
flexible
lightning response who wants to go
please stay within the recommended word
count we are reading thousands of
letters of recommendation
and so the more concise and specific
people can be
the better it is um sometimes the
hardest thing
is when you're trying to find that
reference or that piece of evidence
but you're kind of flipping through a
ton of pages
so again that on the side that we're
humans reading it also be gentle on our
eyes sometimes that
size eight font single space can be
really tough to
to really pull out the meaty examples
i mean we're not sitting there counting
the words so if somebody goes over
slightly we're not going to know the
difference but you know don't write us
a tome and and i think some people think
more is better
and uh that's that's uh i wouldn't i
wouldn't follow that
make it easy for us
awesome thanks y'all um johnny asks one
of my recommenders
and this is also an uploaded question
one of my recommenders will be leaving
my company next month
so he won't have his corporate email and
phone number should i use his personal
contact instead
i believe in that instance you should
contact our
contact us um because then that way they
can verify and give you the full
instructions for that
um nancy in our chat box and q
a um she is one of our experts on the
process and can't confirm that but i
believe that might be the way to go
there
awesome thank you we want to be able to
to reach your recommenders so if their
if their work email is going to be cut
off then i would say yes use their
personal email because we want to be
able to reach them if necessary
awesome thank you all another
upvoted question are the recommenders
allowed some time buffered to submit
their forms
after the deadline for applicants has
passed
um similar to what oil said about word
limit you know
we have a deadline for a reason so we do
appreciate if they
try to now obviously especially um in
places where connections might be slow
or
um things like that if if something does
happen and it comes in after
um reach out to our our desk that we do
um one of our biggest pieces of pieces
of advice at the beginning of this was
to give your
recommenders plenty of time um and in
doing that you're also letting them know
when the deadline is uh and when the
time of that deadline is so hopefully
they're not writing at the last minute
and frantically trying to submit at that
point um so our strongest piece of
advice would be to
to try to get it in at that deadline um
but we do know sometimes things can
happen like
power outages uh internet down
just things that you know we cannot
foresee
um in that case uh like will said reach
out to our our
office but um for the most part we
appreciate if they're in
by the deadline and i would say if your
recommenders having
trouble have them call or email us and
at least let us know
in advance that there's a problem and
and we have tech support
who can help them if they're struggling
with the interface
i have a tip if you're curious about the
status of where your recommend
where that letter is um go to
mystanford.mba there's an
application tracker so that you'll know
once we receive or
once you complete certain parts and that
could also help with
um that upward management piece
so um
one last tactical practical question
in the how to submit section for letters
of reference we're advised to
determine whether or not you will waive
your right to review each recommendation
what should we consider when making this
decision
well the first thing to know is whether
you waive your right
or not has absolutely no impact on how
we
evaluate your recommendations so it has
nothing to do with that it's it's more
about
your right if you
are admitted and you become a student
here if you
have waived your right that means you
cannot
go to your student file and say i want
to see the recommendation
um and if
tell me if i'm saying it wrong but if
you
if you didn't waive your right then
you could go to your student file once
your student here and say i'd like to
see the recommendation
i would say think about your
relationship with your recommender
because sometimes if a recommender knows
that hey that
you know you might be seeing this later
on that may skew the things that they
are sharing in there they might not be
as open
and candid um and they might stay a
little bit more high level so
think about the relationship and
is having that freedom of knowing that
this is going to be
a safe conversation that they are having
with us through the medium of
that letter of reference that they can
be that much more open
truthful and to allison's point
transparent from the very beginning of
the session
let that be one of your guides as you
make the decision of whether or not
you're willing to waive
the right to see your letter later or
not
awesome thank you all um and i just want
to reiterate as
i think has come up throughout this
session when in doubt
just reach out like we know that this
process i know i'm
i'm a poet and i didn't even know it um
you did it again
[Laughter]
we know that this process can feel so
foreign to so many people um both for
applicants and for recommenders so
please feel free to reach out to us we
are we are here to serve you
ultimately um so when in doubt just
reach out
and we read all applications in
context um you know we are not expecting
this process to be
one size fits all we don't expect
people's careers to be one
size fits all so um be reassured that we
read applications in context and if
there's anything that you feel like we
should know as your as we're reading
your application
you can you can certainly feel empowered
to let us know that
um so recordings of this session will be
available
on our youtube channel afterwards so um
you can revisit this
conversation later if you need to you
can direct your letters of
recommendation
writers to this video if you if you need
to
we have about five minutes left
so in these five minutes i would love to
hear
from our panelists any any parting
thoughts
or if there are any myths
about letters of recommendation that
they would like to
myth bust right now i would love to hear
um
love to hear from our panelists final
final words of advice or any myth
busting you would like to do
i have one myth buster that um allison
touched on like
the saying more is not better uh
and so that was with regards to a word
limit but also with the number of
letters of reference
there are some rumors out there that it
might be helpful to go
above the recommended two letters of
reference and i just wanted to
um bust that myth that
yeah more is not better so um there's a
reason we ask for two and
we always appreciate when people do keep
it at two
my advice would be and this isn't just
for the letters of reference this is for
the whole
application process um try not to
uh worry and you know especially worry
over things that you have no control
over you know you don't have any control
over who else applies you don't have any
control ultimately over what your
recommender rights
so you know make your best choices
and then just you know relax and and
and you know uh forget about it and just
don't
don't angst over uh over this whole
process
and then i'll do a little bit more myth
busting
word might be out there that you should
have someone you know
from stanford or with a big like famous
name
writing your letter because that will
help bust that
myth it's not about who's writing the
letter it doesn't matter what their
relationship is to step to stanford
it's what are they writing about you
it's that content that evidence
and sometimes it's maybe that manager
right above you
um who's going to be able to write the
most compelling
thoughtful and supportive recommendation
for you so
release that notion and trust the people
who have worked the closest with you
awesome thank you all so much
um thank you to our panelists for
your incredible words of advice and
wisdom
thank you to our attendees for your
really really thoughtful questions and
for
spending a bit of your day with us today
we're really really grateful for it
you know this application process is
truly a
journey and we hope that this event is
just
one stop along your journey um please
continue your journey at mystanford.mba
will mentioned as a place where you can
track your application
and keep track of your letters of
reference um but it also will
help connect you with opportunities and
events to learn more
um which we know is so important as your
prospective applicant trying to figure
out whether or not stanford is right fit
for you
and how how to navigate this process so
please continue your journey at
mystanford.mba
where you can create a personalized
dashboard track your application
browse courses and clubs find other
events
and connect with student and alumni
stories
this week we'll continue talking about
the application process and we have many
amazing events and we also have events
throughout
the next couple of months to connect you
with students and alumni to hear about
what life is like
at stanford gsb and with that i'll say
my
last thank yous thank you so much to our
panelists thank you to my
admissions colleagues who have been
running the show in the background
and thank you to our attendees for
spending some of your day with us
take care